My muscles are sore, probably because I'm with Barrow's hard
training, so I do that a
lot.Kunigami flew away every day.Are you
here in a hurry?
Why are these lines still
good for the third stage?
Also.  I lost to Ishirin and the others,
took the Bachelor, took the Valor, and was trying to make a run for it. So
now I'm here, so it's ok. That's
how it is. I didn't
see it for a while and it was going through a chaotic situation.
Who is Kunigami teaming up with?  Why did I
get ahead of myself?
Idiot
[Music] Why
didn't you get a hit on me either? Let's do this. Sorry, I was planning to
wait, but
what brought me here? What are you talking about?
What are you doing?  That's the
easiest way for you to take a bath.Well,
I guess I'll join in too.If Nagi invites me, I'll
agree.It's a pain.You
shouldn't swim in a public place called a bath.Well,
look at me, ninja.There's
spit in the bathtub.  You guys must have come in because you've washed your body properly. The
treatment is over. Also, the towels are
dirty, so hurry up, Barrow. You're
such a skinny guy, you're so
picky. Your
next opponent has been decided.  No,
what's going on with them yet? It was
decided that we were going to work with you guys. That's
why I teamed up with these guys.